everyone knows venezuela has gone
through hyperinflation it used to be the
richest country now in the region now it
is not um and it feels like those who
could leave have left
and there's some folks who just can't
leave for whatever reason so they're
stuck there how bad is the situation on
the ground and like what do you see on a
day-to-day basis around the currency or
other businesses yeah
so
[Music]
the situation is really bad
it's been bad for 20 years
um
we have we had a dictatorship uh narco
state
uh the venezuelan regime is uh
sanctioned by ofac uh they all have
prices on their head right by like the
fbi
um and um and that's and they have
control of everything they have total
power
so uh a good example to like
try to bring uh people from the u.s to
what it is over there so the minimum
wage is one dollar currently
in dollar terms
and um
some years the price inflation gets up
to ten thousand percent
so wow yeah in 2019 it was ten thousand
percent so imagine trying to live with
one dollar a month
right like 12 months a year
12
a year and 10 000 price inflation
um how do people do it
i don't know man like it's it's really
hard like peop people are starting
businesses there's a lot of
entrepreneurship that's kind of like one
of the brightest sites of things
there's a very entrepreneurial
vein i would say
and
because
you can start selling food
arepas like cakes to your families to
your friends so you have this like
hybrid local communities
of people selling goods and services to
their community
and everybody sells to each other so
that's a way some some of these
communities are like maintaining
themselves
and more recently since 2019 the the
country started to get dollarized
informally dollarized which means that
um
there's no direct relationship with the
fed
it's it's a dolarization that is coming
in cash and that is coming through
unknown sources
and
so you have kind of like this elites um
having stability and that stability
within the elite
spreads through the kind of like people
around them right
um
so
um that's another way people are kind of
like getting by
um so slowly the country becomes more
and more dollarized uh even though
there's not this direct uh relationship
and also it's a sanctioned country but
as simple as somebody
came to the u.s they got 10 in their
pocket they go back now they have a 10
you know 10 single dollar bills and then
they spend it and it gets into the
economy there's like very low level
examples and i'm sure there's very
complex ways that dollars get into the
economy which i don't want to go there
um but there is some dollarization for
the average person in venezuela right
now as they watch and as you mentioned
in 2019 10 000 inflation what currency
do they want do they want
bolivia do they want dollars they want
gold they want bitcoin they want uh the
euro like how do they think through the
evaluation of their options given that
their currency is basically being
destroyed right before their eyes yeah
so for many years they've they don't
want they haven't
won been wanting the the bolivar the
local fiat
and
in 26
2017 there was a small
uh especially in the young population
but latin america is quite a young
population in general
and uh people were starting to adopt
bitcoin mainly in peer-to-peer exchanges
that was kind of like the main way to do
it
and
because dollars were not an option in
venezuela specifically
while latin america is highly dollarized
and you know argentina you have access
to dollars uh ecuador is fully
dollarized el salvador you have access
to dollars
um
but
in venezuela that was not an option so
at the time crypto was the only option
when the country started to get
dollarized
and because of the fact that dollar the
dollar is trusted by most people outside
the united states
um everybody started to want uh the
dollar specifically
because bitcoin uh price volatility
currently
is too much to sustain for people that
can't save
essentially they don't have the ability
to save they need their money because
they don't make enough
and then there are expenses there
there's basically no delta if i make the
equivalent of five dollars and my
monthly expenses are five dollars i have
nothing to save right that's why they
can't save exactly which is an
opportunity actually uh because
um
the
there's uh
the the middle class is actually
decreasing um
recently there was an article that
sequoia launched that says rising middle
class in latin america there's a bunch
of buzz around latin america
the reality is that it's not rising it's
decreasing and the reason why it's
decreasing is because um there's
multiple kind of like
reasons why that is decreasing but a
good solution for that
is lending lending
money to
small businesses and medium businesses
that have been squeezed by the large
businesses in general there's a huge
wealth inequality
and um
and so if we land in stable currencies
such as the us dollar or in stable coins
people are going to have the ability to
save especially if those uh savings have
interest bearing
yields so
the
uh that's a huge opportunity for crypto
companies
to
kind of like
help the middle class grow
and so yeah
and when you think about what you guys
are doing explain how you're giving
people dollar exposure in that country
so we essentially give them a digital
dollar and um
people the the way they see it is a
digital dollar they don't really care if
it's a stable coins in the back
um what we do is that we partner with
fire blocks a company
from israel and we essentially back
our value dollar we call it the value
dollar which is an iou is centralized
and because of the fact that it's
centralized it allows for people to send
it to each other at no cost it's not
like unchain transactions
because our objective right now is to
prove
that
people and businesses at large like in
the economy they are going to be able to
transition fully
to a dollar based or like digital dollar
economy um
once that problem is solved which is
much harder than just creating a token
right most companies just create a token
and then they figure out oh let's let's
see where can we put it um for us it was
more interesting to figure out how can
we make people and businesses trust in
this digital dollar how can we make them
use it every day
and
so we essentially created this iou
backed in usdc in fireblocks
and
once we reach critical mass we may think
about like hey let's now just give them
exposure to to this token which is going
to be interchangeable for any other
cryptocurrency
uh that they want and how is it going so
far in terms of the and i should have
said this up front i'm an investor in
value so i'm a very big believer in this
but how's it going in terms of getting
the merchant adoption
it's it's been really good actually yeah
so
um an interesting thing that i'm gonna
allude to really quickly is that we
started with remittances to venezuela
because
the we had we now have uh about six
million migrants six to seven million
migrants this is about
one in three venezuelans or one in four
peninsulas have left migrated wow these
people are typically 18 to 40 year olds
for the productive class
and the people that are staying are
younger
people in high school or older people
that are not working as much
so our hypothesis was you know these
people are gonna completely depend on
remittances uh let's help the people
that are migrating send stable coins
rather than send them bolivars which is
the hyper-inflation currency which is
what's already happening at large
venezuela became the second largest
remittance recipient after mexico in the
entire region and mexico of course holds
the number one place because of the u.s
corridor
and um
and so
that was our hypothesis let's dollarize
venezuela through remittances as a
vehicle using kind of like crypto as a
bridge we realized that
we could do it immediately immediate
remittances because of the fact that
it's on crypto
we could do it um
on stable currencies which is a stable
remittances
but the price it's actually not great
because when you want to send um
use money you remittances using crypto
as a bridge you have to go through the
on and off ramps and you have to on ramp
from fiat in the country of the center
and you have to off-ramp in venezuela
because people are not using
crypto as a means of exchange
and it's not being used as a unit of
account in the country so you end up
paying six percent in the on and
off-ramp fees one in one country and the
other one three and three and um that's
not super effective um compared to like
western union and other systems
so
we realized that remittances can only be
effective in crypto
if the the recipient country
has uh uses crypto as a means of
exchange so we've said to ourselves
let's refocus the entire business and to
help businesses use this product
and um it's going really well we changed
this this year at the beginning
and now we have a business account and a
personal account very similar to benmo
here in the united states
um it's just backed in stable coins
and um we're signing up about 150
businesses per day
um and out of those 100 business 50
businesses 50 of them are getting to the
aha moment like experiencing
the core uh
the core value of the product which is
protecting themselves from inflation
they're buying stable coins with their
bully bars or they're charging their
customs customers with bolivars so it's
working it's working really well and our
entire focus is to focus on retention
because
in reality as i mentioned before
technologies change right like
they will continue to change so
for any form of money
retention tells a pretty clear story
on if people really trust in this
product
so um
so now that's what the entire focus of
the company is is on retention for
businesses yeah hey guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today and don't forget to
check out our partner sofi they make all
this possible they're a super app that
lets you save spend borrow earn and
invest all from one single platform and
if you go there today and you sign up
for a sofi invest account you can get
between five dollars and a thousand
bucks for free from sofa not everyone's
obviously gonna get a thousand dollars
but everyone gets something don't say
that i never did anything for you go
check them out at sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
software.compomp and make sure you come
back and watch more of the best business
show we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]